The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Hello.
So today, as people
slowly trickle in,
so today we're going to talk
about scattering states.
So we've spent a lot of time
talking about bound states,
states corresponding
to particles that
are localized in a region and
that can't get off to infinity.
And in particular, when we
distinguish bound states
from scattering
states, we're usually
talking about
energy eigenstates.
They're eigenstates
that are strictly
localized in some region.
For example in the infinite
well, all of the states
are strictly localized
to be inside the well.
In the finite well,
as we saw last time,
there are a finite
number of states,
of energy eigenstates which
are bound inside the well.
But there are also
states that aren't
bound inside the well,
as hopefully you'll
see in recitation,
and as we've discussed
from qualitative structure
of wave functions,
but under the eigenfunction.
So why would we
particularly care?
We also did the
harmonic oscillator
where everything
was nice and bound.
So why would we
particularly care
about states that aren't
bound for scattering states?
And the obvious answer
is, I am not bound.
Most things in the
world are either bound
or they are scattering states.
By scattering state just mean
things that can get away.
Things that can go away.
So it's easy to
under emphasize, it's
easy to miss the importance
of scattering experiments.
It's easy to say look,
a scattering experiment
is where you take
some fixed target
and you throw
something at it and you
look at how things
bounce off and you
try to do something
about this object
by helping it bounce off.
For example, one of the
great experiments of our day
is the LEC, and it's a
gigantic ring, it's huge,
at the foot of the Jura
Mountains outside of Geneva.
And those are people and
that's the detector-- that's
one of the detectors,
I think, at CMS.
And what are you doing
in this experiment?
In this experiment
you're taking two protons
and you're accelerating
them ridiculously fast,
bounded only by the speed
light, but just barely.
Until they have a tremendous
amount of kinetic energy,
and you're colliding
them into each other.
And the idea is if you
collide them into each other
and you watch how the
shrapnel comes flying off,
you can deduce
what must have been
going on when they
actually collided.
You could do something
about the structure.
How are protons built
up out of corks.
And it's easy to
think of a scattering
experiment as some
bizarre thing that
happens in particle
detectors under mountains.
But I am currently engaged
in a scattering experiment.
The scattering experiments
I'm currently engaged in
is light is bouncing from
light sources in the room,
off of very bits of each of you.
And some of it, and probably,
scatters directly into my eye.
That is shocking.
And through the scattering
process and deducing
what I can from the
statistics of the photons
that bounce into my
eye, I could deduce
that you're sitting
there and not over there,
which is pretty awesome.
So we actually get
a tremendous amount
of the information about
the world around us
from scattering processes.
These are not esoteric,
weird things that happen.
Scattering is how you
interact with the world.
So when we do
scattering problems,
it's not because we're thinking
about particle colliders.
It's because at the end of
the day I want to understand--
AUDIENCE: [SNEEZE]
PROFESSOR: --how
surfaces-- bless you--
how surfaces reflect.
I want to understand why when
you look in the mirror light
bounces back.
I want to understand
how you see things.
So this is a much
broader-- scattering's
a much broader idea than
just the sort of legacy
of how we study
particle physics.
Scattering is what
we do constantly.
And we're going to come back
to the computer in a bit.
I'm going to close this for now.
Yes, good.
So today we're going to begin a
series of lectures in which we
study scattering
processes in one
dimension in various
different settings.
So in particular
that means we're
going to be studying
quantum particles being sent
in from some distance,
incident on some potential,
incident on some object.
And we're going to ask how
likely are they to continue
going through, how likely
are they to bounce back.
And so we're going to start
with an easy potential,
an easy object off which
to scatter something, which
is the absence of an
object, the free particle.
And I want to think about
how the system evolves.
So for the free particle where
we just have something of mass,
m, and its potential
is constant,
we know how to solve the--
Question?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: This may
be a little bit dumb,
but given that these
states, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Fantastic question.
I'm going to come
back in just a second.
It's a very good question.
So we're interested
in energy eigenstates,
and we know the
energy eigenstates
for the free particle-- we've
written these down many times--
and I'm going to write
it in the phonic form.
Suppose we have a free
particle in an energy
eigenstate with
energy e, then we
know it's a superposition
of clean waves,
e to the i kx plus
b e to minus ikx.
And the normalization
is encoded in a and b,
but, of course, these
are normalizable states.
We typically normalize
them with a 1
over root 2 pi for delta
function normalizability.
Now, in order for this to be
a solution to the Schrodinger
equation, we need the
frequency or the energy e
is equal to h-bar squared
k squared upon 2m,
and omega is this upon h-bar.
And knowing that,
we can immediately
write down the solution.
Because these are
energy eigenstates,
we can immediately write down
the solution of the Schrodinger
equation, which begins at
time t 0 in this state.
So there's the solution of
the time dependent Schrodinger
equation.
So we've now completely solved
this in full generality, which
is not so shocking since
it's a free particle.
But let's think about what
these two possible states are.
What do these mean?
So the first thing to
say is this component
of our superposition
is a wave, and I'm
going to call it a
right moving wave.
And why am I calling
it a right moving wave?
If you draw the real part of
this, some moment in time,
it's got some crests.
And if you draw on it a
short bit of time later,
I want to ask how
the wave has moved.
And, for example,
a peak in the wave
will be when kx
minus omega t is 0.
If kx minus omega t is 0,
then kx is equal to omega t,
or x is equal to omega over kt.
And assuming as we have
that k is positive,
then this says that
as time increases
the position increases.
And this one, by
exactly the same logic,
x is equal to minus
omega over kt.
So we'll call this a right
going or right moving,
and we'll call this
a left moving wave.
So the general solution is a
superposition, an arbitrary
superposition, of a left
moving and a right moving wave.
This should be familiar from
803 in your study of waves.
But as was pointed
out just a moment ago,
we've got a problem.
Phi e or phi e is
not normalizable.
And this is obvious
from if we-- let's
have b equal 0 for simplicity.
This is a pure phase, and the
norm squared of a pure phase
is 1.
And so the probability
density is constant.
It's 1 from minus
infinity to infinity.
So the probability of finding
it at any given point is equal.
So assuming this is on
the real line, which
is what we mean by saying
it's a free particle,
there's no constant you
can multiply that by
to make it normalizable.
This is not a
normalizable function.
So more precisely,
what we usually do
is we take our states phi
sub k equal 1 over root 2 pi,
e to the i kx.
Such that phi k, phi k
prime is equal to delta.
Sorry-- that's not
what I wanted to write.
Such that-- well, fine.
Phi k, phi k prime is equal
to delta of k minus k prime.
This is as good as we can do.
This is good as we
get to normalizing it.
It's not normalized to 1.
It's normalized 1k
is equal to k prime,
to the value of the delta
function, which is ill-defined.
So we've dealt with this
before, we've talked about it.
So how do we deal with it?
Well, we've just
learned, actually,
a very important thing.
This question,
very good question,
led to a very important
observation which
is that can a particle, can
a quantum mechanical particle
be placed, meaningfully
said to be placed,
in an energy eigenstate
which is bound?
Can you put a particle
in the ground state
of a harmonic oscillator?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
That's fine.
Can you put the
particle in the k
equals 7 state of
a free particle?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
So these scattering
states, you can never
truly put your particle
truly in a scattering state.
It's always going to be
some approximate plane wave.
Scattering states
are always going
to be some plane
wave asymptotically.
So we can't put the particles
directly in a plane wave.
What can we do, however?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
We can build a wave packet.
We can use these as
a basis for states,
which are normalizable
and reasonably localized.
So we need to deal
with wave packets.
So today is going to be,
the beginning of today
is going to be dealing with
the evolution of a wave packet.
And in particular
we'll start by looking
at the evolution in time
of a well localized wave
packet in the
potential corresponding
to a free particle.
And from that we're
going to learn already
some interesting
things, and we'll
use that intuition for the
next several lectures as well.
Questions before we get going?
All right.
So here's going to
be my first example.
So consider for
the free particle
or consider a free particle
in a minimum uncertainty wave
packet.
So what is a minimum
uncertainty wave packet.
We've talked--
AUDIENCE: A Gaussian.
PROFESSOR: A Gaussian, exactly.
So the minimum uncertainly
wave packet's a Gaussian.
Suppose that I take my particle
and I place it at time 0,
x0 in a Gaussian.
I'm going to properly
normalize this Gaussian.
I hate these factors
of pi, but whatever.
a root pi, e to the minus
x squared over 2a squared.
So this is the wave function
at time 0, I declare.
I will just prepare the
system in this state.
And what I'm
interested in knowing
is how does the
system evolve in time?
What is x psi of x and t?
So how do we solve this problem?
Well, we could just plug it
into the Schrodinger equation
directly and just by brute
force try to crank it out.
But the easier thing to do
is to use the same technique
we've used all the way along.
We are going to take
the wave function,
known wave function,
known dependence on x,
expand it as a superposition
of energy eigenstates.
Each energy eigenstates
evolved in a known fashion
will evolve those
energy eigenstates
in that superposition, and
do the sum again, re-sum it,
to get the evolution as
a function of position.
Cool?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So given that
the x-basis and the t-bases
are uncountable, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Good.
Here's the theorem.
So the question is roughly how
do you know you can do that?
How do you know you can
expand in the energy.
And we have to go back to the
spectral theorem which tells us
for any observable, the
corresponding operator
has a basis of eigenfunctions.
So this is a theorem
that I haven't proven,
but that I'm telling you.
And that we will
use over and over
and over again,
spectral theorem.
But what it tells you is that
any operator has an eigenbasis.
So if we find any good operator
corresponding to an observable
has a good eigenbasis.
That means that if we find the
eigenfunctions of the energy
operator, any state
can be expanded
as a superposition
in that state.
And the question of
accountable versus uncountable
is a slightly subtle one.
For example, how many points
are there on the circle?
Well, there's an
uncountable number.
How many momentum modes
are there on a circle?
Well, that's countable.
How does that work?
How can you describe
that both in position
and in momentum space.
Ask me afterwards and we'll
talk about that in more detail.
But don't get too hung up on
countable versus uncountable.
It's not that big a difference.
You're just summing--
it's just whether you
sum over a continuous
or discrete thing.
I'm being glib, but it's useful
to be glib at that level.
Other questions before we-- OK.
Good.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So the reason we are
going to use energy eigenstates
is just because [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Almost.
So the question is are we
using the energy eigenstates
because at the end
of the day it's
going to boil down to
doing a Fourier transform,
because the energy eigenstates
are just plain waves,
e to the ix?
And that will be true, but
that's not the reason we do it.
It's a good question.
So let me disentangle these.
Well, I guess I can use this.
The point is that if I
know that si-- for any wave
function in any system, if
I know that phi of x at 0
is some function, and I
know the energy eigenstates
of that system, then I can
write this as sum over n, of cn,
phi n of x for some
set of coefficient cn.
So that's the spectral theorem.
Pick an operator
here, the energy.
Consider its eigenfunctions.
They form a basis and any
state can be expanded.
But once we've expanded
in the energy eigenbasis,
specifically for the
energy eigenbasis
where e phi n is
en phi n, then we
know how these guys
evolve in time.
They evolve by an e to the
minus i en t upon h-bar.
And we also know that
the Schrodinger equation
is a linear equation, so
we can superpose solutions
and get a new solution.
So now, this is the expression
for the full solution
at time t.
That's why we're using
energy eigenstates.
In this simple case
of the free particle,
it is a felicitous fact that
the energy eigenstates are also
Fourier modes.
But that won't be
true in general.
For example, in the
harmonic oscillator system,
the harmonic oscillator
energy eigenstates
are Gaussians times
some special functions.
And we know how to compute them.
That's great.
We use a raising,
lowering operators.
It's nice.
But they're not plane waves.
Nonetheless, despite
not being Fourier modes,
we can always expand
an arbitrary function
in the energy eigenbasis.
And once we've done so,
writing down the time evolution
is straightforward.
That answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Great.
Anything else?
OK.
So let's do it for this guy.
So what are the
energy eigenstates.
They're these guys,
and I'm just going
to write it as e to the
i kx without assuming
that k is positive.
So k could be
positive or negative,
and energy is e to the
h-bar squared k squared.
And so we can write this as--
we can write the wave function
in this fashion,
but we could also
write it in Fourier
transformed form,
which is integral
dk upon root 2 pi
for minus infinity to infinity.
I'm mostly not going
to write the bounds.
They're always going to be
minus infinity to infinity.
Of dk 1 over root
2 pi e to the i kx.
The plane wave times the Fourier
transform, psi tilde of k.
So here all I'm doing is
defining for you the psi tilde.
But you actually
computed this, so this
is the Fourier transfer.
You actually computed this on,
I think, the second problem set.
So this is equal to the
integral dk over root 2 pi
e to the i kx.
And I'm going to get
the coefficients-- I'm
going to be careful
about the coefficients a,
so root a over 4 [INAUDIBLE] pi.
e to the minus k squared
a squared over 2.
So here, this is
just to remind us
if we have a
Gaussian of width a,
the Fourier transform is
Gaussian of width 1 upon a.
So that's momentum and position
uncertainty in Fourier space.
And you did this
in problem set two.
So this is an alternate way
of writing this wave function
through its Fourier transform.
Everyone cool with that?
But the nice thing
about this is that we
know how to time evolve
this wave function.
This tells us that that psi
of xt is equal to integral--
and I'm going to get these
coefficients all pulled out--
integral of root a over root pi.
Integral dk upon root 2 pi.
e to the i kx minus omega t.
And remember, Omega
it depends on k,
because it's h-bar
squared k squared
upon 2m divided by h-bar.
Times our Gaussian,
e to the minus
k squared a squared upon 2.
So everyone cool with that?
So all I've done is
I've taken this line,
I pulled out the
constant, and I've
added the time evolution
of the Fourier mode.
So now we have this integral
to give us the full,
OK, so now we just have
to do the integral.
And this is not so hard to do.
But what makes it totally
tractable is that if I just
do this with some
function of omega of k--
I mean that's complicated,
know how to do that integral.
But I happen to know that e
is h-bar squared k squared
upon 2m, which
means that omega is
equal to h-bar k
squared upon 2m.
So I can rewrite this as
minus h-bar k squared upon 2m.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Where is the
fourth [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's a square
root of a square root.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I didn't see it.
My bad.
PROFESSOR: No, no.
That's OK.
It's a horrible,
horrible factor.
So what do we take
away from this?
Well, this can be
written in a nice form.
Note that here we
have a k squared,
here we have a k squared,
here we have a k.
This is an integral over k,
so this is still Gaussian.
It's still the exponential
of a quadratic function of k.
So we can use our formulas
for Gaussian integrals
to do this integral.
So to make that a
little more obvious,
let's simplify the form of this.
So the form of
this is again going
to be square root of
a over square root pi.
Integral dk upon root 2 pi.
e to the i kx.
And I'm going to take this
term and this term and group
them together because
they both have
a k squared in the exponential.
e to the minus k
squared upon 2 times--
now instead of just a squared,
we have a squared plus i h-bar
upon 2m t-- there's
a typo in my notes.
Crap.
Good.
So before we do
anything else, let's
just check dimensional analysis.
This has units of one
of length squared.
So this had better have
units of length squared.
That's a length squared, good.
This, is this a length squared?
So that's momentum
times length, which
is mass times length over time.
Divide by mass, multiplied by
time, so that's length squared.
Good.
So our units make sense.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
PROFESSOR: This, too, we need.
AUDIENCE: In terms of 2m.
PROFESSOR: Oh, this one.
Good.
Thank you.
Yes.
Thanks.
So this is again a Gaussian.
And look, before we
knew we have a Gaussian,
the Fourier transform
is just this Gaussian.
The only difference is it's
now a Gaussian with width.
Not a, but a complex number.
But if you go through the
analysis of the Gaussian
integral, that's perfectly fine.
It's not a problem at all.
The effective width is this.
So what does that tell
you about psi of t?
So this tells you
that psi of x and t
is equal to root a over root pi.
And now the width.
So we have the 1 over root a.
But now the effective width
is this guy, a squared
plus-- so it's square root of
a squared plus i h-bar upon mt.
e to the minus x squared
over 4a squared plus-- oops,
where did my 4-- there's
a 2 that-- there's
a spurious 2 somewhere.
I'm not sure where
that 2 came from.
There should be a 2 there.
a squared plus i h-bar upon mt.
So at this point it's not
totally transparent to me
what exactly this wave
function is telling me,
because there's still a phase
downstairs in the width.
So to get a little
more intuition let's
look at something
that's purely real.
Let's look at the probability
to find the particle
at position x at time t.
That's just the norm
squared of this guy.
And if you go through a
little bit of algebra,
this is equal to 1
over root pi times--
I'm going to write out
three factors-- times 1
over square root of-- yes,
good-- a squared plus h-bar
upon 2ma squared
t squared times e
to the minus x squared upon
2a squared plus h-bar squared
over 2ma squared.
Oops-- h-bar over 2ma squared t.
So what do we get?
The probability distribution
is again a Gaussian.
But at any given
moment in time--
this should be t squared--
at any given moment in time
the width is changing.
The width of this Gaussian
is changing in time.
Notice this is
purely real again.
And meanwhile, the
amplitude is also changing.
And notice that it's changing
in the following way.
At time 0, this is the
least it can possibly be.
At time 0 this
denominator is the least
it can possibly be
because that's gone.
At any positive
time, the denominator
is larger so the
probability has dropped off.
So the probability at any
given point is decreasing.
Except for we also
have this Gaussian
whose width is increasing
in time, quadratically.
It's getting wider
and wider and wider.
And you can check-- so
let's check dimensional
analysis again.
This should have units
of length squared,
and so this is
momentum times length
divided by length divided by
mass-- that's just a velocity.
So this is the velocity
squared times squared.
That's good.
So this has the correct units.
So it's spreading
with the velocity
v is equal to h-bar upon 2ma.
And what was a? a was
the width at times
0. a was the minimum width.
So graphically, let's roll this
out-- what is this telling us?
And incidentally, a
quick check, if this
is supposed to be the
wave function at time t,
it had better reproduce the
correct answer at time 0.
So what is this wave
function at time 0?
We lose that, we lose that, and
we recover the original wave
function.
So that's good.
So graphically what's going on?
So let's plot p of x and t.
At time 0 we have a Gaussian
and it's centered at 0,
and it's got a width,
which is just a.
And this is at time t equals 0.
At a subsequent time,
it's again centered
at x equals 0--
modulating my bad art--
but it's got a width, which
is a squared square root
of a squared plus h-bar
upon 2ma squared, t squared.
So it's become
shorter and wider such
that it's still
properly normalized.
And at much later
time it will be
a much lower and much
broader Gaussian.
Again, properly normalized, and
again centered at x equals 0.
Is that cool?
So what this says
is if you start
with your well-localized
wave packet and you let go,
it disperses.
Does that make sense?
Is that reasonable?
How about this.
What happens if you ran the
system backwards in time?
If it's dispersing
and getting wider,
then intuitively
you might expect
that it'll get more sharp, if
you integrated it back in time.
But, in fact, what happens
if we take t negative
in this analysis?
We didn't assume it
was positive, anyway.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It disperses again.
It comes from being a
very dispersed wave,
to whap, to being very
well [INAUDIBLE], and whap,
it disperses out again.
And notice that the sharper the
wave function was localized,
the smaller a was in the first
place, the faster it disperses.
This has 1 upon a.
It has an a downstairs.
So the more sharp
it was at time 0,
the faster it disperses away.
This is what our
analysis predicts.
So let me give you two
questions to think about.
I'm not going to
answer them right now.
I want you to think about
them-- not right-- well,
think about them now,
but also think about them
more broadly as you
do the problem set
and as you're reading through
the reading for the next week.
So the width in this example
was least at time t equals 0.
Why?
How could you build a wave
function, how could you
take this result and build a
wave function whose width was
minimum at some other
time, say, time t0.
So that's one question.
Second question.
This wave function
is sitting still.
How do you make it move?
And either the second or the
third problem on the problem
set is an introduction
to that question.
So here's a challenge
to everyone.
Construct a
well-localized wave packet
that's moving, in the sense that
it has well-defined momentum
expectation value.
And again, hint, look at
your second or third problem
on the problem set.
And then repeat
this entire analysis
and check how the probability
distribution evolves in time.
And in particular,
what I'd like to do
is verify that the probability
distribution disperses,
but simultaneously
moves in the direction
corresponding to the initial
momentum with that momentum.
The center of the
wave packet moves
according to the momentum that
you gave it in the first place.
It's a free particle so
should the expectation value,
the momentum change over time?
No.
And indeed it won't.
So that's a challenge for you.
OK, questions at this point?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So this wave or this
Gaussian's not moving,
but it's centered over
0 at time 0 or x0?
PROFESSOR: Sorry, this
is at x is equal to 0.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So is that-- so all
those [INAUDIBLE]
are at x equals 0 over here.
Shouldn't the amplitude
increase and not the--
PROFESSOR: Good.
So what I'm plotting-- sorry.
So I'm plotting p of
x and t as a function
of x for different times.
So this is time 0.
This was time t equals
something not 0, equals 1.
And this is some time
t equal to large.
Right.
AUDIENCE: And so but
is it if x is always 0,
then shouldn't the
[INAUDIBLE] not change
because it would
equal [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Good.
So if x is 0, then the
Gaussian contribution
is always giving me 1.
But there's still
this amplitude.
And the amplitude
is the denominator
is getting larger
and larger with time.
So, indeed, the amplitude
should be falling off.
Is that--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but
will the width change?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, absolutely.
So what the width is, the
width is saying, look,
how rapidly as we increase x,
how rapidly does this fall off
as a Gaussian.
And so if time is increasing,
if time is very, very
large, than this
denominator's huge.
So in order for this Gaussian
to suppress the wave function,
x has to be very, very large.
AUDIENCE: So we're assuming
[INAUDIBLE] x hasn't changed.
PROFESSOR: Ah, good.
Remember, so this x is not
the position of the particle.
x is the position at which we're
evaluating the probability.
So what we're plotting
is we're plotting-- good.
Yeah, this is an easy
thing to get confused by.
What is this
quantity telling us?
This quantity is telling us the
probability, the probability
[INAUDIBLE, that we find
the particle at position
x at time t.
So the x is like, look,
where do you want to look?
You tell me the x and
I tell you how likely
it is to be found there.
So what this is telling
us is that the probability
distribution to find the
particles start out sharply
peaked, but then it becomes
more more and more dispersed.
So at the initial
time, how likely
am I to find the
particle, say, here?
Not at all.
But at a very late time, who
knows, it could be there.
I mean my confidence
is very, very limited
because the probability
distribution's very wide.
Did that answer your question.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Great.
Yup?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] what
happens after [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Excellent question.
That's a fantastic question.
So we've talked about
measurement of position.
We've talked about
measure-- So after you
measure an
observable, the system
is left in an eigenstate of
the observable corresponding
to the observed eigenvalue.
So suppose I have some potential
or I have some particle
and it's moving around.
It's in some complicated wave
function, and some complicated
state.
And then you measure
its position to be here.
But my measurement
isn't perfect.
I know it's here with some
reasonable confidence,
with some reasonable width.
What's going to be
the state thereafter?
Well, it's going to be
in a state corresponding
to being more or less here
with some uncertainty.
Oh look, there's that state.
And what happened subsequently?
What happened subsequently
is my probability immediately
decreases.
And this is exactly
what we saw before.
Thank you for asking
this question.
It's a very good question.
This is exactly
what we said before.
If we can make an arbitrarily
precise measurement
of the position, what
would be the width?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It'd be delta, so
with width would be 0.
That little a would be 0.
So how rapidly does it disperse?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Pretty fast.
And you have to
worry a little bit
because that's getting
a little relativistic.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you make a
measurement that's not perfect,
how do you account
for that [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So OK.
That's a good question.
So you make a measurement,
it's not perfect,
there was some uncertainty.
And so let me rephrase
this question slightly.
So here's another
version of this question.
Suppose I make a
measurement of the system.
If there are two possible
configurations, two
possible states,
and they measure
an eigenvalue corresponding
to one of them,
then I know what state
the system is in.
And then again, if I'm measuring
something like position
where I'm inescapably
going to be measuring
that position with
some uncertainty,
what state is it
left in afterwards?
Do I know what state
it's left in afterwards?
No, I-- I know
approximately what state.
It's going to be
a state corr-- OK,
so then I have to have some
model for the probability
distribution of
being in a state.
But usually what
we'll do is we'll
say we'll approximate that.
We'll model that unknown.
We don't know
exactly what state it
is because we don't know exactly
what position we measured.
Well, model that by
saying, look, by the law
of large numbers it's going to
be roughly a Gaussian centered
around the position
with the width, which
is our expected uncertainty.
Now, it depends on exactly
what measurement you're doing.
Sometimes that's not
the right thing to do,
but that's sort of a
maximally naive thing.
This is an interesting
but complicated question,
so come ask me in office hours.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if this
probability isn't moving,
what is that velocity we
[INAUDIBLE] over there?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
So what is this velocity?
So this velocity,
what is it telling us?
It's telling us how rapidly
the wave spreads out.
So does that indicate
anything moving?
No.
What's the expected value
of the position at any time?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: 0, because
this is an even function.
What's the position?
Well, it's just as likely
to be here as here.
It's just that the
probability of being here
gets greater and greater
over time for a while
and then it falls off
because the Gaussian
is spreading and falling.
Yeah.
One last question.
Yup.
AUDIENCE: Can you tell
me a little bit more
about negative time is
the same as positive time?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So the question is can
you talk a little bit more
about why the behavior
as time increases
is the same as the behavior
as we go backwards in time.
And I'm not sure how
best to answer that,
but let me give it a go.
So the first thing is to
say look at our solution
and look at the
probability distribution.
The probability distribution
is completely even in time.
It depends only on t squared.
So if I ask what
happens at time t,
it's the same as what
happened at time minus t.
That's interesting in a
slightly unusual situation.
Let's look back at
the wave function.
Is that true of
the wave function?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No.
Because the phase
and the complex parts
depend on-- OK, so the
amplitude doesn't depend on
whether it's t or minus t.
But the phase does.
And that's a useful clue.
Here's a better way.
What was the weird thing that
made this t reversal invariant?
There's another weird
property of this,
which is that it's
centered at 0.
It's sitting still.
If we had given it momentum that
would also not have been true.
So the best answer I
can give you, though,
requires knowing
what happens when
you have a finite momentum.
So let me just sketch quickly.
So when we have a momentum,
how do we take this wave packet
and give it momentum k naught?
So this is problem three
on your problem set,
but I will answer it for you.
You'd multiply by phase
e to the i k naught x.
And the expectation
value will now
shift to be h-bar k
naught for momentum.
So what's that
going to do for us?
Well, as we do the
Fourier transform,
that's going to shift
k to k minus k naught.
And so we can repeat
the entire analysis
and get roughly k
and k naught here.
The important thing is
that we end up with phases.
So the way to read
off time 0 is going
to be-- well, many
answers to this.
As time increases or decreases,
we'll see from this phase
that the entire wave packet
is going to continue moving,
it's going to continue
walking across.
And that breaks the
t minus t invariance.
Because at minus t it
would have been over here.
And then think about
that first question.
How would you make it
become minimum wave packet
at some time which
is not time equals 0?
So when you have
answers to both of those
you'll have the answer
to your question.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What
does it really mean
for us to say that we have
a probability distribution
and measure something
like negative time?
Because it seems like we did
something at time equals 0,
and we say the
probability that we
would have found it
[INAUDIBLE] is here.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: It seems that you
have to be aware [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Good.
So that's not exactly what the
probability of distribution
is telling us.
So what the probability
and distribution is telling
you is not what happens
when you make a measurement.
It's given this state
what would happen?
And so when you ask about
the probability distribution
at time minus 7,
what you're saying
is given the wave
function now, what must
the wave function have
been a time earlier,
such that Schrodinger
evolution, not measurement,
but Shrodinger evolution
gives you this.
So what that's telling you is
someone earlier-- had someone
earlier been around
to do that experiment,
what value would they have got?
AUDIENCE: But wouldn't
that have changed
the wave function of that?
PROFESSOR: Absolutely, if
they had done the measurement.
There's a difference between
knowing what the probability
distribution would be if you
were to do a measurement,
and actually doing a measurement
and changing the wave function.
AUDIENCE: So for
the negative time,
is it the earlier statement
about what the wave function--
PROFESSOR: It's merely
saying about what the wave
function was at an earlier time.
AUDIENCE: It doesn't
really have measurements.
PROFESSOR: No one's done
any measurements, exactly.
Writing down the
probability distribution
does not do a measurement.
Exactly.
One last question.
Sorry, I really-- Yup.
AUDIENCE: Why define it
negative 2, and then prepares
the states and
its width times 0?
PROFESSOR: Well, you
could ask the question
slightly differently.
If you had wanted to prepare
the state at time minus 7 such
that you got this
state at time 0--
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: This is
the inverse of asking
given that the state
is prepared now,
what is it going
to be at time 7.
So they're equally
reasonable questions.
What should you
have done last week
so that you got your
problem set turned in today?
There was no problem
set due today.
OK, so with that said, we've
done an analytic analysis--
that was ridiculous-- we've done
a quick computation that showed
analytically what happens
to a Gaussian wave packet.
We've done an analysis
that showed us
how the wave function
evolved over time.
What I'd like to do now is use
some of the PhET simulations
to see this effect, and also
to predict some more effects.
So what I want you to
think about this as,
so this is the PhET quantum
tunneling wave packet
simulation.
If you haven't played with
these, you totally should.
They're fantastic.
They're a great way of
developing some intuition.
All props to the Colorado group.
They're excellent.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to run through a
series of experiments
that we could, in principle,
do on a table top,
although it would be
fabulously difficult.
But the basic physics is simple.
Instead I'm going to run them
on the computer on the table top
because it's easier and cheaper.
But I want you to think
of these as experiments
that we're actually running.
So here, what these diagram
show, for those of you who
haven't played
with this, is this
is the potential that I'm
going to be working with.
The green, this
position, tells me
the actual value of the
energy of my wave packet.
And the width tells me how
broad that wave packet is.
And roughly speaking,
how green it is
tells me how much support I
have on that particular energy
eigenstate.
And I can change that by tuning
the initial width of the wave
packet.
So if I make width
very narrow, I
need lots and lots of
different energy eigenstates
to make an narrow
well-localized wave packet.
And if I allow the wave
packet to be quite wide,
then I don't need as
many energy eigenstates.
So let me make that a
little more obvious.
So fewer energy
eigenstates are needed,
so we have a thinner
band in energy,
more energy
eigenstates are needed,
so I have more wide band.
Is everyone cool with that?
And what this program does is it
just integrates the Schrodinger
equation-- well,
yeah, well it just
integrates the
Schrodinger equation.
So what I want to do is
I want to quickly-- oops.
So this is the wave
function, its absolute value.
And this is the probability
density, the norm squared.
So let's see what happened.
So what is this initial state?
This initial
state-- in fact, I'm
going to re-load
the configuration.
So this initial
state corresponds
to being more or less here
with some uncertainty.
So that's our psi of x0.
And let's see how this evolves.
So first, before you
actually have it evolved,
what do you think
is going to happen?
And remember, it's got some
initial momentum as well.
OK.
So there it is evolving and
it's continuing to evolve,
and it's really quite boring.
This is a free particle.
Wow, that was dull.
OK, so let's try that again.
Let's look also at
the real part and look
at what the phase of the
wave function's doing.
So here there's something
really cool going on.
It might not be obvious.
But look back at this.
Look at how rapidly
the wave packet moves
and how rapidly the phase moves.
Which one's moving faster?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
the wave packet.
And the wave
packet, it's kind of
hard to tell exactly how
much faster it's moving.
But we can get that from this.
What's the velocity of a
single plane wave or the phase
velocity?
So the phase
velocity from problem
set one is h-bar k squared upon
2m-- let me write this as omega
upon k, which is just
equal to h-bar k upon 2m.
But that's bad because
that's the momentum.
Divide the momentum by the mass,
that's the classical velocity.
So this says that the
phase of any plane wave
is moving with half
the classical velocity.
That's weird.
On the other hand,
the group velocity
of a wave packet, of a
normalizable wave packet
is do mega dk.
And do mega dk will pull it
down an extra factor of 2.
This Is equal to h-bar k upon m.
This is the classical velocity.
So this is the difference
between the phase and the group
velocity, and that's exactly
what we're seeing here.
So the first thing
you notice is you
see the difference between the
phase and the group velocity.
So that's good.
That should be reassuring.
But there's
something else that's
really quite nice about this.
Let's make the wave
packet really very narrow.
So here it's much more
narrow, and let's let
the system evolve.
And now you can see that
the probability density
is falling off quite rapidly.
Let's see that again.
Cool.
The probability distribution
is falling off very rapidly.
And there's also kind
of a cool thing that's
happening is you're seeing
an accumulation of phase
up here and a
diminution down here.
We can make that a
little more sharp.
Oops, sorry.
Yeah.
So that is a combination
of good things
and the code being
slightly badly behaved.
So the more narrow I
make that initial--
so let's-- so I made
that really narrow,
and how rapidly
does it fall off?
So that very narrow
wave packet by time 10
is like at a quarter.
But if we made it much wider,
that very narrow wave packet
started out much lower and it
stays roughly the same height.
It's just diminishing
very, very slowly.
And that's just the
1 over a effect.
So this is nice.
And I guess the way I'd
like to think about this
is this is confirming rather
nicely, our predictions.
So now I want to take a
slightly different system.
So this system is really
silly because we all
know what's going to happen.
Here's a hill, and if
this were the real world
I would think of this as
some potential hill that
has some nice finite fall off.
The sort of place you don't
want to go skiing off.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, I don't.
So imagine you take
an object of mass m
and you let it slide along
in this potential, what
will happen?
It will move along
at some velocity.
It will get to this cliff,
it will fall off the cliff
and end up going much
faster at the bottom.
Yeah?
So if you kick it here,
it will get over there
and it will end up much faster.
What happens to
this wave packet.
So we're solving the
Schrodinger equation.
It's exactly the same
thing we've done before.
Let's solve it.
So here's our
initial wave packet,
nice and well-localized.
There's our wave function.
And what happens?
So at that point something
interesting has happened.
You see that for the most
part, most of the probability
is over here, but not all
the probability is over here.
There's still a
finite probability
that the particle stays
near the wall for a while.
Let's watch what happens to that
probability as time goes by.
And now you should
notice that it's
decayed into a
wave packet that's
over here, and then a
superposition of a wave
packet over here
moving to the left.
This wave has scattered off
the barrier going downhill.
It's mostly transmitted,
but some of it reflected.
Which is kind of spooky.
So let's watch that-- I'm going
to make this much more extreme.
So here's a much more
extreme version of this.
I'm now going to
make the energy very
close to the height
of the potential.
The energy is very, very close
to the height of the potential,
and the potential is far away.
We're still reasonably local--
I can make it a little less
localized just to really
crank up the suspense.
So watch what happens now.
So first off, what do
you expect to happen?
So we've made the energy
of the wave packet
just barely higher than
the energy of the hill.
So it's almost classically
disallowed from being up here.
What does that mean
about its velocity?
It's effective loss.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The momentum, the expectation
value for momentum
should be very low
because it just
has a little bit
of spare energy.
So the expected value for the
momentum should be very low.
It should dribble, dribble,
dribble, dribble, dribble,
dribble, dribble till it
gets to the cliff, and then--
[WHISTLE]-- go flying off.
So let's see if
that's what we see.
So it's dribbling, but look
at the probability density
down here.
Oh, indeed, we do
see little waves,
and those waves are
moving off really fast.
But the amplitude is
exceedingly small.
Instead, what we're seeing is
a huge pile up of probability
just before the wall, similar
to what we saw a minute ago.
Except the probability
is much, much larger.
And what's going to happen now?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's leaking.
It's definitely leaking.
But an awful lot of
the probability density
is not going off the cliff.
This would be Thelma and
Louise cruising off the cliff
and then just not falling.
This is a very disconcerting--
you guys get to-- yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
So see what happens,
see what happened here.
We've got this nice big
amplitude to go across
or to reflect back,
to scatter back.
You really want to
fall down classically,
but quantum
mechanically you can't.
It's impossible.
So, in fact, the probability
they reflect back is 41,
and we're going to
see how to calculate
that in the next few lectures.
Yup.
AUDIENCE: So the transmission
was actually really high.
PROFESSOR: Transition
was reasonably high, yup.
AUDIENCE: And it was
really [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It wasn't
really, sorry?
AUDIENCE: It wasn't really
apparent graphically.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
it wasn't apparent.
The way it was apparent
was just the fact
that the amplitude that bounced
back was relatively small.
So what was going is any
little bit of probability that
fell down had a large
effective momentum.
Just ran off the
screen very rapidly.
So it's hard to see that in
the simulation, it's true.
We can make the-- we can
squeeze-- ah, there we go.
So here is-- that's
about as good
as I'm going to be able to get.
And it's just going
to be glacially slow.
But this is just going to
be preposterously slow.
I'm not even sure
there's much point
in-- But you can see
what's going to happen.
They're going to build up, we're
going to get a little leak off,
but for the most part,
the wave packet's
going to go back to the left.
Questions about this one
before we move on to the next?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Are
the-- Yeah, exactly.
So r and t here are going to
be defined as the probability
that this wave packet
gets off to infinity
in either direction.
AUDIENCE: What happens if you
make the energy lower than--
PROFESSOR: Then you
can't have a wave
packet on the left
that's moving.
Because remember that
the wave packet in order
to have an expected momentum
needs to be oscillating.
But if the energy is lower than
the potential, its exponential.
So the expectation value
for the momentum is 0.
So you can't have a particle
moving in from the left
if it's got energy less than
the height of the barrier.
Cool?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, what's
this green thing?
PROFESSOR: The green thing is
the energy of the wave packet
that I'm sending in.
OK, so let's go to the next one.
So this is something
we'd like to understand.
The reason I'm
showing you this is I
want to explain this phenomena.
We already did the dispersion.
I want to explain this
phenomena that you reflect
when going downhill, which
is perhaps surprising.
And I want to ask how
efficiently do reflect off
any given barrier.
Yeah.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Can you describe the
[INAUDIBLE] physical experiment
that would show
that done, though?
PROFESSOR: Oh yeah, absolutely.
So suppose I have a
little capacitor plate
and there's a potential
difference across it
and a hole so a particle
could shoot threw it.
I mean it doesn't have to
be an insanely small hole,
but a hole.
So that if a particle
goes from here
to the other side of
the capacitor plate,
it will have accelerated across
the potential difference.
So if you think about the
effective potential energy,
the potential is
decreasing linearly.
It's a constant electric field.
So over this short domain
between the capacitor plates,
we have effectively a
linear potential energy.
So I have a particle that I
send with very little momentum,
but it carries some charge.
It gets on capacitor
plates, and if it
goes through the
capacitor plate,
it ends with a lot
more energy relative
to the potential energy.
That cool?
So a little capacitor
plate with a hole in it
is a beautiful example
of this system.
Good?
Now, making it infinitely
sharp, well, that
would require-- you know.
But making it very
sharp is no problem.
So here's the inverse
of what we just did,
which is sending a
particle into a barrier.
And so there you see it does
some quite awesome things.
And I want to pause
it right here.
This is the energy band.
So the green
represents-- it says
that at any given energy
inside this green band,
there's some contribution
from the corresponding energy
eigenstate to our wave packet.
There isn't any
contribution from states
up here where there's
no green, which
means that all the
contributions come
from energy
eigenstates with energy
below the height of the barrier.
None of them have enough
energy to cross the barrier.
And what we see when we
send in our wave packet
is some complicated mucking
around near the barrier,
but in particular,
right there, there's
a finite non-zero
probability that you're
found in the classically
disallowed region.
In the region where you
didn't have enough energy
to get there.
We see right there.
And meanwhile, there's
also a huge pile up here.
This is a hard wall.
Normally classically
from a hard wall,
you roll along, you
hit the hard wall,
and you bounce off
instantaneously
with the same velocity.
But here what we're
saying is no, the wave
doesn't just exactly
bounce off instantaneously.
We get this complicated piling
up and the interference effect.
So what's going on there?
Well, it's precisely
an interference effect.
So look at the wave function.
The wave function is a much
easier thing to look at.
So the red is the amplitude.
The red is the real part.
The black is the phase.
So the real part is actually
behaving quite reasonably.
It looks like it's just
bouncing right off.
But the physical thing is
the probability distribution.
The probability distribution
has interference terms
from the various
different contributions
to the wave function.
So at the collision those
interference effects
are very important.
And at late times
notice what's happened.
At late times the
probability distribution
all went right back off.
So that's something else
we'd like to understand.
Penetration into the
barrier from a classically
disallowed wave packet.
Yup.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the wave
packet is also expanding again?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The wave packet, exactly.
So the wave packet is
always going to expand.
And the reason is we're
taking our wave packet, which
is a reasonably well-localized
approximately Gaussian wave
packet.
So whatever else is
going on, while it's
in the part of the potential
where the potential is
constant, it's also
just dispersing.
And so we can see that here.
Let's make that more obvious.
Let's make the initial wave
packet much more narrow.
So if the wave packet's
much more narrow,
we're going to
watch it disperse,
and let's move the
wall over here.
So long before it hits the wall
it's going to disperse, right?
That's what we'd expect.
And lo, watch it disperse.
OK, now gets to the wall.
And it's sort of a mess.
Now, you see that there's
contributions to the wave
function over here,
there's support
for the wave function
moving off to the right.
But now notice that we have
support on energy eigenstates
with energy above the barrier.
So, indeed, it was possible
for some contribution
to go off to the right.
So one more of these guys.
I guess two more.
These are fun.
So here's a hard wall.
Let's make the-- So
here's a hard wall.
But it's a finite width barrier.
What happens?
Well, this is basically the
same as what we just saw.
We collide up against
that first wall,
and since there's
an exponential fall
off it doesn't really
matter that there's
this other wall where
it falls down over here
because the wave function is
just exponentially suppressed
in the classically
disallowed region.
So let's see that again.
It's always going to be
exponentially suppressed
in the classically
disallowed region.
As you see, there's that
big exponential suppression.
So there's some
finite particle here,
but you're really unlikely to
find it out here exponentially.
On the other hand, if we
make the barrier-- so let's
think about this barrier.
Classically, this is just
as good as a thick barrier.
You can't get passed this wall.
But quantum mechanically
what happens?
You go right through.
Just--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: --right on--
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, uh-huh.
Right through.
It barely even changes shape.
Just goes right on through.
Now, there's some probability
that you go off to the left,
that you bounce off.
[LAUGHTER]
I share your pain.
I totally do.
So I would like to do another
experiment which demonstrates
the difference between classical
and quantum mechanical physics.
Right.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
So we have some
explaining to do.
And this is going to turn
out to be-- surprisingly,
this is not a hard
thing to explain.
It's going to be real easy.
Just like the
dispersion, this is
going to be not a
hard thing to explain.
But the next one and this
is-- oh yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: Does the height
of the spike matter?
PROFESSOR: It does, absolutely.
So the height of the spike and
the width of the spike matter.
So let's make it a little wider.
And what we're going
to see now is oh, it's
a little less likely
to go through.
If we make it just
a tiny bit wider
we'll see that it's much
less likely to go through.
We'll see much stronger
reflected wave.
So both the height and width
are going to turn out to matter.
So here you can see that there's
an appreciable reflection,
which there wasn't previously.
Let's make it just
a little bit wider.
And now it's an awful lot
closer to half and half.
See the bottom two lumps?
Let's make it just
ever so slightly wider.
And again, looking
down here we're
going to have a transmitted
bit, but we're also
going to have a
reflected-- now it
looks like the reflected bit is
even a little bit larger maybe.
And we can actually compute the
reflection transmission here.
72% gets reflected and
28% get transmitted.
I really strongly encourage you
to play with these simulations.
They're both fun and
very illuminating.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
just the higher it got,
the less got transmitted?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So if this were
a delta function would
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well,
what's the width?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: So what
happens when we
make the well less and
less-- or more and more thin?
More, yeah, through.
So we've got a competition
between the heights
and the width.
So one of the problems
on your problem set,
either this week or next
week, I can't recall,
will be for the delta
function barrier,
compute the transmission
probability.
And, in fact, we're going to ask
you to compute the transmission
probability through
two delta functions.
And, in fact, that's this week.
And then next week
we're going to show you
a sneaky way of using
something called the S
matrix to construct bound
states for those guys.
Anyway, OK.
So next, the last
simulation today.
So this is the inverse
of what we just did.
Instead of having a
potential barrier,
we have a potential well.
So what do you expect to happen?
Well, there's our wave
packet, and it comes along,
and all heck breaks
loose inside.
We get some excitations
and it tunnels across.
But we see there's all
this sort of wiggling
around inside the wave function.
And we get some support
going off to the right,
some support going
off to the left.
But nothing sticks
around inside,
which it looks like
there is, but it's
going to slowly decay away as
it goes off to the boundary.
These are scattering states.
So one way to think about
what's going on here
is it first scatters off,
it scatters downhill,
and then it scatters uphill.
But there's a very
funny thing that
happens when you can scatter
uphill and scatter downhill.
As we saw, any time you
have scattering uphill
and there's some probability--
that you reflected
some probability
that you transmit.
And we scatter uphill.
There's some probability
you transmit,
and some probability
that you reflect.
But if you have both an
uphill and a downhill
when you have a well,
something amazing happens.
Consider this well.
This didn't work very well.
Let's take a much larger one.
Uh-hmm!
So at some point, I
think it was last year,
some student's cell phone
went off, and I was like oh,
come on, dude.
You can't do that.
And like five minutes later
my cell phone went off.
[LAUGHTER]
So I feel your pain, but please
don't let that happen again.
So here we go.
So this is a very similar
system-- well, the same system,
but with a different
wave packet,
and a slightly different width.
And now what happens?
Well, all this wave packet
just sort of goes on,
but how much probability is
going back off to the left?
Very little.
In fact, we can
really work this.
Sorry, I need this, otherwise
I'm very bad at this.
There's some probability that
reflects in the first well.
reflects in the second well.
But the probability
that reflects
from the combination
of the two, 0.
How can that be?
So this is just like the
boxes at the very beginning.
There's some probability.
So to go in this system-- so
let's go back to the beginning.
There's some amplitude
to go from the left side
to the right-hand side by
going-- so how would you
go from the left-hand side
to the right-hand side?
You transmit and
then transmit, right?
So it's the transmission
amplitude times transmission
amplitude gives you the product.
But is that the only
thing that could happen?
What are other possible
things that could happen?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You could transmit,
reflect, reflect, transmit.
You could also transmit,
reflect, reflect,
reflect, reflect, transmit.
And you could do that an
arbitrary number of times.
And each of those
contributions is
a contribution to the amplitude.
And when you compute the
probability of transmit,
you don't take some
of the probabilities.
You take the square of
the sum of the amplitudes.
And what we will
find when we-- I
guess we'll do this next
time when we actually
do this calculation-- is
that that interference
effect from taking the square
of the sum of the amplitudes
from each of the
possible bouncings
can interfere
destructively and it
can interfere constructively.
We can find points when the
reflection is extremely low.
And we can find points where
the transmission is perfect.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So two questions.
One, the computer says that the
reflection coefficient is 0.
Why did it look like it there
was a wave packet going off
back to the left?
PROFESSOR: Excellent question.
And, indeed, there
is a little bit here.
So now I have to tell you
a little bit about how
the computer is casting
this reflection amplitude.
The way it's doing
that is it's saying
suppose I have a state
which has a definite energy
at the center of
this distribution.
Then the corresponding
reflection amplitude
would be 0.
But, in fact, I have
a superposition.
I've taken a
superposition of them.
And so the contributions from
slightly different energies
are giving me some
small reflection.
AUDIENCE: And also,
why do you have
to fine-tune the
width of that as well?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's a really-- let me
rephrase the question.
The question is why do
you have to fine-tune
the width of that well?
Let me ask the question
slightly differently.
How does the
reflection probability
depend on the width of the well?
What's going on at these
special values of the energy
or special values of
the width of the well
when the transmission
is perfect?
Which I will call a resonance.
Why is that happening?
And we'll see that.
So that's a question I
want you guys to ask.
So I'm done now with
the experiments.
You guys should play with
these on your own time
to get some intuition.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Isn't the
[INAUDIBLE] you just
showed actually a classical
[INAUDIBLE] objects?
PROFESSOR: So excellent.
So here's what
I'm going to tell.
I'm going to tell
you two things.
First off, if I take a
classical particle and I
put it through these potentials,
for example, this potential.
If I take a classical particle
and I put it in this potential,
it's got an energy here,
does it ever reflect back?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
Always, always it
rolls and continues on.
Always.
So if I take a quantum
particle and I do this,
will it reflect back?
AUDIENCE: Sometimes.
PROFESSOR: Apparently sometimes.
Now, how do I encode that?
I encode that in studying the
solutions to the wave equation
dt minus-- sorry--
i h-bar dt psi
is equal to minus
h-bar squared upon 2m,
dt squared psi plus v psi.
So this property of the quantum
particle that it reflects
is a property of solutions
to this equation.
When I interpret the amplitude
squared as a probability.
But this equation
doesn't just govern--
this isn't the only place that
this equation's ever shown up.
An equation at least
very similar to this
shows up in studying
the propagation of waves
on a string, for example.
Where the potential is played
by the role of the tension
or the density of the string.
So as you have a wave
coming along the string,
as I'm sure you did
in 803, you have
a wave coming along a string.
And then the thickness or
density of the string changes,
becomes thicker or
thinner, then sometimes
you have reflections
off that interference--
from impedance mismatch
is one way to phrase it.
And as you move across
to the other side
you get reflections again.
And the thing that
matters is not
the amplitude of the--
one of the things
that matters is
not the amplitude,
but it's the intensity.
And the intensity's a square.
And so you get
interference effects.
So, indeed, this phenomena
of reflection and multiple
reflection shows up in
certain classical systems,
but it shows up not in
classical particle systems.
It shows up in classical wave
systems, like waves on a chain
or waves in a rope.
And they're governed by
effectively the same equations,
not exactly, but effectively
the same equations,
as the Schrodinger evolution
governs the wave function.
But the difference is that
those classical fields,
those classical continuous
objects have waves on them,
but those waves
are actual waves.
You see the rope.
The rope is everywhere.
In the case of the quantum
mechanical description
of a particle, the
particle could be anywhere,
but it is a particle.
It is a chunk, it is a thing.
And this wave is a probability
wave in our knowledge
or our command of the system.
Other questions?
OK.
So let's do the first example
of this kind of system.
So let's do the very first
example we talked about, apart
from the free particle,
which is the potential step.
First example is
the potential step.
And what we want
to do is we want
to find the eigenfunctions
of the following potential.
Constant, barrier, constant.
And I'm going to call
the height here V
naught, and the height here 0.
And I'll call this
position X equals 0.
And I want to send
in a wave-- think
about the physics of sending in
a particle that has an energy E
naught.
Now to think about the
dynamics, before we
think about time evolution
of a localized wave packet,
as we saw in the
free particle, it
behooves us to find
the energy eigenstates,
then we can deduce the
evolution of the wave packet
by doing a re-summation by using
the superposition principle.
So let's first find
the energy eigenstates.
And, in fact, this
will turn out to encode
all the information we need.
So we want to find phi e of x.
What is the energy eigenfunction
with energy E, let's say.
And we know the
answer on this side
and we know the
because it's just constant.
That's a free particle and we
know how to write the solution.
So we can write this
as this is equal to.
On the left-hand side it's
just a sum of plane waves.
It's exactly of that form.
a e to the i kx plus b
e to the minus i kx on the left.
And on the right we have c e
to the minus i alpha x-- sorry.
On this side it's disallowed,
classically disallowed.
So this is e to
the minus-- sorry,
do you-- plus alpha x
plus d e to minus alpha x.
Where h-bar squared k squared
upon 2m is equal to e.
And h-bar squared
alpha squared upon 2m
is equal to v naught minus
e, the positive quantity.
So we need to satisfy
our various continuity
and normalizability conditions.
And in particular, what had
the wave function better do out
this way?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It had
better not divert--
are we going to be able to build
normalizable wave packets--
or are we going to be able
to find normalizable wave
functions of this form?
No.
Because there are always going
to plane waves on the left.
So the best we'll be able
to do is find delta function
normalizable energy eigenstates.
That's not such a
big deal because we
can build wave packets,
as we discussed before.
But on the other
hand, it's one thing
to be delta function
normalizable going
to just a wave, it's
another thing to diverge.
So if we want to build
something that's normalizable up
to a delta function
normalization condition,
this had better vanish.
Yeah?
But on top of that, we
need that the wave function
is continuous, so at x equals
we need that phi and phi
prime are continuous.
So that turns out to be
an easy set of equations.
So for phi, this says that
a plus b is equal to d.
And for phi prime,
this says that ik a.
And then the next one is going
to give me minus ik a minus b
is equal to, on the right-hand
side, minus alpha c.
Because the exponential's
all value to 0.
So we can invert
these to get that d
is equal to 2-- that's weird.
AUDIENCE: You have
a d in the bottom.
There's [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh,
sorry. d. d. d. d. d.
Thank you.
To invert those you get 2k
over k plus i alpha, I think?
Yes.
And b is equal to k minus i
alpha over k plus i alpha.
And so you can
plug these back in
and get the explicit form
of the wave function.
Now, what condition
must the energy satisfy
order that this is a
solution that's continuous
and derivative is continuous?
Last time we found that in order
to satisfy for the finite well,
the continuity normalizability
conditions, only certain values
of the energy were allowed.
Here we've imposed
normalizability and continuity.
What's the condition
on the energy?
This is a trick question.
There isn't any.
For any energy we
could find a solution.
There was no consistency
condition amongst these.
Any energy.
So are the energy eigenvalues
continuous or discrete?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Continuous.
Anything above 0 energy
is allowed for the system,
it's continuous.
So what does this wave
function look like?
Oh, I really should have
done this on the clean board.
What does this wave
function look like?
Well, it's oscillating out
here, and it's decaying in here,
and it's smooth.
So what's the meaning of this?
What's the physical meaning?
Well, here's the way I
want to interpret this.
How does this system
evolve in time?
How does this wave
function evolve in time?
So this is psi of x.
What's psi of x and t?
Well, it just gets hit
by an e to the minus
i omega t minus omega t plus
omega t minus i omega t.
Everyone cool with that?
So all I did is I
just said that this
is an energy eigenfunction
with energy e,
and frequency omega is
equal to e upon h-bar.
And saying that this is an
energy eigenstate tells you
that under time evolution,
it evolves by rotation
by an overall phase, e
to the minus i omega t.
And then I just multiplied
the whole thing by e
to the minus i omega
t and distributed it.
So here's the minus
i omega t minus i
omega t minus i
omega t in the phase.
So doing that, though, gives
us a simple interpretation.
Compared to our free particle,
e to the i kx minus omega t,
it's a wave moving to the
right with velocity omega
over k, the phase velocity.
This is a right-moving
contribution.
So plus.
And this is a
left-moving contribution.
Everyone cool with that?
So on the left-hand
side, what we
have is a superposition
of a wave moving
to the right and a wave
moving to the left.
Yeah?
On the right, what do we have?
We have an exponentially falling
function whose phase rotates.
Is this a traveling wave?
No.
It doesn't have any crests.
It just has an overall
phase that rotates.
And now here's one key thing.
If we look at this, what's b?
We did the
calculation of v. v is
k minus i alpha
over k plus i alpha.
What's the norm
square root of b?
Well, the norm
square root of b is
going to be multiply this
by its complex conjugate,
multiply this by its
complex conjugate.
But their each other's complex
conjugates will cancel.
The norm squared is 1.
So pure phase.
So this tells you
b is a pure phase.
So now look back at this.
If b is a pure phase--
sorry-- if b is a pure phase,
than this left-moving piece
has the same amplitude
as the right-moving piece.
This is a standing wave.
All it's doing is it's
rotating by an overall phase.
But it's a standing
wave because it's
a superposition of a wave
moving this way and a wave
moving that way with
the same amplitude.
Just slightly shifted.
So the fact that
there's a little shift
tells you that it's norm
squared is not constant.
It has a small wave.
So what we see is we
get a standing wave that
matches nicely onto a
decaying exponential
in this classically
disallowed region.
So what that tells you
is what's the probability
to get arbitrarily
far to the right?
0.
It's exponentially suppressed.
What's the probability that your
found some point on the left?
Well, it's the norm
squared of that,
which is some standing wave.
So the reflection of how
good is this is a mirror.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's
a perfect mirror.
Well, it's not-- Now
we have to quibble
about what you mean
by perfect mirror.
It reflects with a phase.
It reflects with a
phase beta, and I'm
going to call that phase-- I
want to pick conventions here
that are consistent throughout.
Let's call that e to the i phi.
So it reflects with
a phase phi, which
is to say that
[INAUDIBLE] squared is 1.
And what happens-- I
don't want to do this.
So in what situation
would you expect
this to be a truly perfect
mirror, this potential?
When do you expect reflection
to be truly perfect?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
So if the height here
were infinitely high,
then there's no probability.
You can't leak in at all.
There's no exponential tail.
It's just 0.
So in the case that v0 is much
greater than e, what do we get?
We get that v0 is
much greater than e.
That means alpha's gigantic,
and k is very, very small.
If alpha is gigantic and k is
very small, negligibly small,
than this just becomes
minus i alpha over i alpha.
This just becomes
minus 1 in that limit.
So in the limit that the wall
is really a truly hard wall,
this phase becomes minus 1.
What happens to a wave when it
bounces off a perfect mirror?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Its phase
is inverted, exactly.
Here we see that the
phase shift is pi.
You get a minus 1 precisely when
the barrier is infinitely high.
When the barrier's
a finite height,
classically it would be
a perfect mirror still.
But quantum mechanically it's
no longer a perfect mirror.
There's a phase
shift which indicates
that the wave is extending a
little bit into the material.
The wave is extending
a little bit
into the classically
disallowed region.
This phase shift, called
the scattering phase shift,
is going to play a
huge role for us.
It encodes an enormous
amount of the physics,
as we'll see over
the next few weeks.
At the end of the semester
it'll be important for us
in our discussion
of bands and solids.
So at this point, though, we've
got a challenge ahead of us.
I'm going to be using
phrases like this
is the part of the wave
function moving to the right,
and that's the part of the wave
function moving to the left.
I'm going to say
the wave function is
a superposition of
those two things.
But I need a more
precise version of stuff
is going to the right.
And this is where the
probability density,
phi squared, and the probability
current, which you guys
have constructed on the problem
set, which is h-bar upon 2mi.
Psi star dx i minus
psi dx psi star.
These guys satisfy the
conservation equation
which is d RHO dt.
The time rate of
change of the density
at some particular
point at time t
is equal to minus the gradient,
derivative with respect
to x, of j.
And I should really
call this jx.
So the current in
the x direction.
So this is the
conservation equation,
just like for the
conservation of charge,
and you guys should have
all effectively derived
this on the problem set.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is the i under
or above [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Is the i-- oh,
sorry, the i is below.
That's just my
horrible handwriting.
So what I want to
define very quickly
is I want to be able to come up
with an unambiguous definition
of how much stuff is
going left and how much
stuff is going right.
And the way I'm
going to do that is
I'm going to say that the
wave function in general--
I'll do that here-- when we have
a wave function at some point.
It can be approximated
if the potential is
roughly constant at that point.
It can be approximated
in the following way.
The wave function
is going to be psi
is equal to psi
incident plus psi
transmitted--
yeah, psi reflected
on the left of my barrier.
And psi transmitted
on the right.
Where psi incident is
that right-moving part.
The part that's moving
towards the barrier.
Psi reflected is the left-moving
part that's reflected.
Psi transmitted is
the part that is
on the right-hand
side, the entire thing.
So here the idea is I'm sending
in something from the left.
It can either reflect
or it can transmit.
So this is just my notation
for this for these guys.
And so what I wanted
to measure of how much
stuff is going left, how
much stuff is going right.
And the way to do that is to
use the probability current.
And to say that associated to
the incident term in the wave
function is an
incident current, which
is h-bar k upon
m from a squared.
So if we take this wave
function, take that expression,
plug it into j, this
is what you get.
If you take the reflected
part b to the minus i kx
minus omega d, and you plug it
into the current expression,
you get the part of-- sorry,
I should call this capital
J-- you get the part of
the current corresponding
to the reflected term, which
is h-bar k with a minus k
upon m v squared.
And we'll get that
J transmitted is 0.
Something that you proved
on your problem set.
If the wave function is real,
it must-- the current to 0.
So let's think about what
this is telling us quickly.
So what is this [INAUDIBLE]?
So what is a current?
A current is the amount of
stuff moving per unit time.
So charge times the velocity.
So what's the stuff
we're interested in?
It's the probability density.
There's a squared.
Norm a squared.
That's the
probability amplitude,
or probability density of
the right-moving piece.
Just consider it in isolation.
So that's the
probability density.
It's the amount of stuff.
And this is the momentum of
that wave, that's e to the i kx.
There's h-bar k.
That's the momentum
divided by the mass, which
is the classical velocity.
The amount of stuff
times the velocity.
That a current.
It's the current with
which probability
is flowing across a point.
Similarly, Jr, that's the amount
of stuff, and the velocity
is minus h-bar k upon m.
So again, the
current is the amount
of stuff times the velocity.
I'm going to define-- this
is just the definition,
it's the reasonable
choice of definition--
the transmission probability
is the ratio, the norm squared
of J transmitted
over J incident.
And here's why this is the
reasonable thing-- oops--
incident.
Here's why this is the
reasonable quantity.
This is saying how much current
is moving in from the left?
How much stuff is moving in
from-- And how much stuff
is moving off on the
right, to the right?
So what is this in this case?
0, although this is
a general definition.
And similarly, the reflection
you can either write as 1
minus the transmission, because
either you transmit or you
reflect, the probability
must sum to 1.
Or you can write r as
the current reflected.
What fraction of the incident
current is, in fact, reflected?
And here this is 1.
Because beta-- b is a phase,
and the norm squared of a phase
is 1.
So on your problems
set, you'll be
going through the computation
of various reflection
and transmission amplitudes
for this potential.
And we'll pick up on this with
the barrier uphill next week.
Have a good spring break, guys.